gloria thank you so much
for talking today
let's focus on that bombshell leak from
the supreme court were you shocked
well i was shocked by
the unprecedented leak of a draft
opinion from the u.s supreme court uh
we've never seen anything like this
before
but more importantly the shock was
that there is a majority on the u.s
supreme court who is not just going to
chip away at roe v wade
the 1973 united states supreme court
decision that found that women have a
constitutional right to legal and safe
abortions at least at certain stages of
their pregnancy but instead the majority
is going to strike it down completely
and this of course is catastrophic and
it's dangerous to the lives and the
health of women and gloria i wonder
actually when i s i saw the leak i
wondered whether it had been leaked
because people
someone wanted it out there in order to
try and stoke up enough
resistance
that the leak document might get changed
to explain it to our viewers is this the
end of the constitutional protection for
abortion perhaps forever or do you think
that the leaked document
given the reaction in the u.s might get
changed
i think it's highly unlikely that the
decision of the majority will change
it's possible is it probable
not likely
so we have to prepare for the day
when we lose the constitutional right to
choose abortion and remembering the
victims who are going to be most at risk
and those are young women those are poor
women those are women of color those are
women who are
rural women
and
those women are most vulnerable those
four categories because often they don't
have the money to travel to another
state in the united states like
california where i am now new york some
other states haven states where abortion
will remain legal because we are
pro-choice states
and so they don't have money to put
gasoline in their car if they even have
a car or to buy a train ticket or a bus
ticket they don't have money for child
care to take care of their other
children while they travel to get an
abortion so this is mandatory motherhood
this is deciding that a fertilized egg
has more rights than an adult woman and
that is dangerous it is wrong even
teenagers who get pregnant beth
and have their parents consent to get an
abortion in some of these states they
won't be able to get it
in some of these states they're even
outlawing medicaid uh medication
abortions meaning taking a pill in your
own home to self-induce an abortion
which is important because half of all
abortions in the united states are
medication abortions and they're
often to get the pill in the mail they
have to have a consultation with a
doctor online telemedicine and many
states are outlawing that that's what's
at stake um can congress simply where do
you go from here can congress simply
legislate to replicate
that constitutional protection for women
is that an option
yes beth and that's what the president
meant when he said it could be codified
the women's health protection act has
already been passed by the house of
representatives but we all know it's
unlikely to even be voted on by the
united states senate because they will
filibuster keep talking and not allow a
vote because many of the anti-choice
politicians are cowards and they don't
want people to know that they'll vote
against the women's health protection
act and so we have to fight you know who
knows maybe we're going to have to add
justices to the u.s supreme court uh you
know we're going to have to also fight
state by state i wanted to talk to you
about your story actually um because
this is personal for you isn't it you
were one of those women
and now you're very very frightened
about this happening to other women can
you briefly tell us your story
i'm more than frightened i'm angry i'm
fired up and i'm ready to go to fight to
battle and i will be speaking at the
la city hall
rally on may 14th
and they're going to be rallies all over
this country
pro-choice rallies in every state on
that date
yes it is personal for me
because i had to pay someone who was not
licensed to perform abortions after i
was raped at gunpoint in mexico when i
was on vacation there and returned to
california when i was in my 20s and
before roe v wade made abortion safe and
legal
and then
i had to
have an ambulance called be taken to the
hospital with 106 degree fever packed in
ice and that's where a nurse said to me
i hope this teaches you a lesson
meaning she was anti-choice it did teach
me a lesson but the lesson was that
abortion must be safe and legal and
affordable and available and that is why
i have been fighting uh for pro-choice
uh laws and uh to preserve roe v wade
for
all of my professional life 47 years in
law practice and even before that and we
must protect because women will die and
will be maimed by illegal abortion or be
compelled to take pregnancies to term
when they're not ready and able uh uh to
support
uh a as a child that may be born so this
is a dangerous time and we must fight
back and just to pick up something you
said you you said that one option would
be to add justices
to the supreme court is that something
that president biden
could try to do how would that work
well you know that's that's an option
it's a very difficult one it's a very
controversial one
but you know these are
extreme times and uh
and we know that
and so you know i mean how extreme does
it get
how much dream more does it get when in
some states they're even
requiring rape victims children who are
victims of incest to give birth and not
be able to get an abortion
so you know we're going to explore all
options
all options are going to be on the table
yes this is radical as the president has
said and it is radicalizing women and
girls in this nation in the way it never
has before
so get ready we're going to be exploring
all options it's not going to be just an
academic task we are going to take to
the streets we are going to take to the
courts we are going to uh go in the
court of public opinion and we are going
to do everything that is legal and not
necessarily peaceful to win our rights
and we are going to get out the vote in
every election now uh and we are going
to vote because our lives depend on it
and that is why
we will and
gloria just rode and wade roe versus
wade it seemed permanent i remember
studying it at school
uh it was past 49 years ago when you
were just a young woman did you ever
because i don't think i did did you ever
imagine it might be overturned and do
you see this as a colossal failure of
the american left of the woman's
movement do you must feel quite angry at
your country at the moment do you
well all i can say is
the anti-choice forces have not stopped
since roe v wade
in challenging it
they have filed many lawsuits some of
which have gone to the supreme court and
in every state
so they have been fighting they have
been shipping away
and now it's the ultimate time for them
uh they are people celebrating that they
get to control women and their choices
and their lives but we are going to show
them
that we have uh you know we have the
determination and the persistence we
will resist we will persist and we will
insist
that women's rights be respected
and i believe that we will win it will
be a battle but we
expect to and intend to
win this war against women thank you so
much gloria i really appreciated your
time thank you thanks for coming on the
show
anytime